Let me just show you some examples
of what we mean by tracking.
And here is some slightly older ones.
The one on the left here is
this girl jumping around.
You see the little red
ring around her head.
That's, I think that's Andrew Blake's
daughter a long time ago.
I think she's now a lawyer.
So that tells you something
about the time difference.
Andrew, I have no idea if that's true.
And also from a similar work is
this leaf blowing in the wind.
And you'll notice,
as the camera zooms in and
out and things move around, it does a
pretty good job of sticking to the leaf.
Both of these examples were work
that Andrew and Michael Isard did in
the particular type of tracking that
we'll actually do not this lecture, but
a couple lessons from now.
Here is a slightly more recent one.
This is a tracking of body
parts as somebody's moving.
And you can see the,
the reference there.
And again, this is a tracking problem,
but it's tracking with a model.
Right?
So the idea is I
want to be able to track
where the parts have moved.
Here you see a sort of a more
traditional notion of tracking.
But in this case,
it's lots of targets, right?
So there are a lot of people say
walking around in the street here.
And you'll notice that it
does a really good job
of keeping track of all the people.
The little box that's
around each one of them and
there's another little
box that's on their head.
Here there's just a little bit of
animation showing you that it's
tracking them through spacetime, right?
So this volume with these
trajectories through there
are showing you how it's doing
the reasoning over spacetime.
There are a couple of interesting
things to notice here.
Watch this guy going behind the pole.
All right, so he goes behind the pole
and he appears the other side.
And you might ask, how does it do that?
>> How does it do that?
>> I'm not going to tell you yet.
I'll tell you soon.
And also here, it's showing you just the
heads that have been tracked to show you
that it's recovered that.
So this is an example of sort of a state
of the art tracking at least of a,
of a couple of years ago.